if you're concerned about the security
of your PlayStation Network account then
have no fear Sony has enabled 2-step
verification I'm Lucy and welcome to
your secure GameSpot news update on the
PlayStation website Sony said passwords
can be compromised if you use the same
password for multiple accounts click on
malicious links open phishing emails and
other methods if your password is
compromised and becomes known to someone
other than yourself your account will
still require a verification code to
gain access when you activate 2-step
verification with 2-step verification
enabled a text message will be sent to a
linked mobile phone number when you type
in and enter your password the code
sends in this text needs to be entered
before you can be granted access to the
account Sony added by requiring two
forms of identification for sign in your
account and personal information will be
better protected in other PlayStation
news Sony is expected to unveil its new
upgraded PlayStation 4 in September at
the PlayStation meeting the event takes
place on September 7th at 3 p.m. Eastern
time and will be held at the PlayStation
Theatre in New York so you can add
2-step verification to your account or
do you like to live dangerously let me
know in the comments below or come find
me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James games
for more on Playstation make sure you
keep it GameSpot